Conrad ASCA was born in 1974 in the tiny
Caribbean nation of Antigua and by every
account he was an outstanding person
Conrad was the leader of the family said
his brother we all looked up to him eska
was certainly a man of deep religious
faith and we know that because his final
words in the second before his death
were quote Lord you now have my soul
imagine saying that as your final
sentence
but his death is a scandal the reason he
died is a scandal and many in the
aviation industry know about it but it
is never mentioned in public so we
thought we would tell you because there
are lessons in his death for all of us
who travel commercially in February of
2019 ASCO was the first officer piloting
an Amazon Prime cargo jet
for a contractor called Atlas Air they
were flying a Boeing 767 at as a as it
approached Houston Airport ASCA assumed
full control of the plane so seconds
later while attempting to apply the
speed brakes to land ASCA accidentally
pressed to switch that put the plane
into go around mode and that gave the
plane an unexpected jolt of thrust
in response to this unexpected jolt ask
a panicked instead of checking his
instruments to figure out what was going
on he pushed down hard on the control
yoke he pushed as hard as he could and
then the plane nosedive through the
clouds and right into the water
the plane was obliterated on impact it
killed him his co-pilot and another
pilot who was just hitching a ride
so it was obvious from those facts alone
that Conrad asked a decent man though he
was should not have been in control of
an airplane
and his Personnel records confirmed that
strongly before he started flying 767s
for Amazon and Atlas Air he had been a
pilot for seven different airlines
including Mesa Airlines
several instructors at Mesa reported
that ask it was often overwhelmed in the
cockpit as he was on the day he died One
Pilot later told the NTSB that in
emergencies ask a quote became extremely
anxious and would start pushing a lot of
buttons without thinking about what he
was pushing just to be doing something
to be clear for a pilot that can be
deadly and it was Atlas Air says it was
not aware of any of this when it hired
ASCA but once he arrived at Atlas Air
ask it was so deficient in the simulator
that all Pilots have to train on that
the company had to restart simulator
training just for him all of his other
classmates had graduated
predictably in its final report into the
atlas air crash the NTSB cited as a
cause of the deadly crash the quote
systemic deficiencies in the aviation
industry's selection and performance
measurement practices which failed to
address the first officers aptitude
related deficiencies and maladaptive
stress response
by the way those are things that all
Airlines and the military screen for and
have since Aviation began
and ask his family
lost their son and husband and brother
knew that and so they have gone on to
file several lawsuits against Atlas Air
and Amazon for gross negligence
specifically for putting this man in the
cockpit despite his obvious inability to
fly an airplane
so why was he flying an airplane
well in his specific case we do not have
a definitive answer but it seems pretty
obvious
Airlines like Atlas Air in fact all the
airlines are doing their best to hire
and retrain pilots on the basis of
irrelevant criteria like their
appearance and your appearance to
restate has nothing to do with your
ability to fly an airplane or perform
heart surgery or do anything it's
immaterial
but on their websites both Amazon and
Atlas Air explained that quote diversity
is Paramount in everything they do
here's from the Atlas Air website quote
we leverage diversity equity and
inclusion Dei as a business strategy and
Driver of innovation we are Guided by
Dei philosophy oh yes well apparently
you are look at the results Amazon of
course says the same thing
this is not an outlier this is not just
happening at Atlas Air this is happening
at every major carrier in the United
States safety concerns ignored in favor
of something called Equity hiring by
appearance not by ability this is insane
and in this case it killed three people
United Airlines has promised that 50
percent of their new trainees will be
quote women and minorities
right not the best Pilots but people who
look a certain way well as we told you
in December a United Boeing triple seven
Bound for San Francisco came within
seconds of hitting the ocean it just
dropped out of the sky and the pilots
who apparently were not properly trained
or hired for the wrong reasons on the
basis of irrelevant criteria were sent
back to training thankfully the hundreds
of people on that plane survived
but this kind of thing is happening
across the industry talk to anyone who
works there talk to any working pilot
right now the airlines are in a mad
scramble to meet equity
targets meaning they are pushing safety
aside in favor of ideology and people
will die people have died
it's going to happen again
this should stop
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight